I am from a small town in northwest Alabama. And, in that place, and at
the time I was growing up, um, it was about
buttoning yourself and, being tucked in, and hiding things away. Because
although, um, you know, all the farms in the textile mills, on the outside,
just on the edge of those mills was Mother Nature. And, she was always so
close just right to that edge of all that cultivation. And
so, in my part of the world, um, you know, a house that's left
alone or not cared for can really melt down into this
fertile wet, uh, green mass where
animals and kudzu wait to grow into the buildings.
And so, um, you know, people hoe and they cut things back.
They keep it pruned, and they, uh, watch, and wait for
that little slip that's going to come through.
So, uh, there's this moment in my childhood where I'm walking down the stairs of the church
and my...um, a friend of the family is coming up the stairs and she looks at my
cousin Pam and she goes, "Pam, you have just grown up to be the most
beautiful young woman.
Just stunning."  And, she looks over at me and she goes,
"And Natalie, you're so..so...exotic."
[laughter]
And, you know,
sitting here today, I look back and I know that what she was trying to say
was this.. there felt there's this little piece of that outside
that she could smell underneath, and it scared her.
And so, you know, I hit the ground running just as fast as I could
to get away from
being tied up. And, nature, and I tried
to run towards exotic and what I thought
I could find in the world. And I traveled around the world and I came
back again.
And I learned how to, uh...I did things I never
imagined I could have done as a rur...a girl rural
Alabama. But, there was a night I arrived, uh, back in
New York in the year 2000. I was, uh, moving away from a marriage
that was gone wrong.
I was questioning and not finding answers. And
that night when I arrived, it was snowing outside. And, I was really cold
and, uh, lost. And all of
the...um, everything was raw.
And I was invited one night to what I deemed this really fancy fashion party,
like only New York City can do. Right?
And, so I had been wallowing in my self-
discovery or you could call it self-pity during this time. And I was
pretty broke. [laughs]
And, I didn't have anything to wear to this party. So,
I took a t-shirt out of my...my backpack and I cut it up. And, I
kind of pinned together on my body. And I sewed it back together again with needle and
thread. And, so I went to the party that night, and the strangest thing happened.
That people would, like, see me across the room, and they would walk across the room, and kind of
touch my body, which, uh, people in New York City
don't really do, you know. [laughter] You know, in the south, you hug
people whether you like them or
not. [laughter]
But, um, people in New York City don't really do that. But people were touching me, and they were
asking, you know, what do you...What is that? What do you have on?
And, so the next morning, I, uh, I woke up. And, you know, I was really
proud that people had liked my shirt that I had found this
approval from the fancy fashion folk. But, what really struck me that morning when I
woke up was that, although I had been a designer and a stylist
for really long time, it had also
been equally as long since I had made something with my own two hands. And I felt so, uh,
moved to get up that morning and make another t-shirt. And so, I made another t-shirt and another
t-shirt. And, I just kept making shirts, and I kept wearing them, and people would stop me on
the street and they would touch me.
And, in the middle of all this making and touching, I had this vision that I wanted to see these
200 one-of-a-kind cut up t-shirts
sewn back together again and laid out on the
floor. And, so I started going around to manufacturers the New York. These
bags of Salvation Army/Goodwill collected throwaway things that
were cut apart and, um,
you know they thought I was a crazy bag lady.
And, so, uh, rejection after rejection (Uh, excuse me.)
Nobody really wanted me to, uh, to help me make these shirts. And, so I'm standing on the street
corner on Eighth and 38th one afternoon, and I'm looking down at the t-shirt, and I'm like,
It's a quilting stitch. And, I realized in that moment that I was going to have
to go home
because all of the ladies who quilted with my grandmothers were still
there in Alabama quilting, and I was like:
This is such a great idea. In my mind, I thought, "This is gonna be
so great. I'm gonna to go home. They're gonna to love to do this. This is gonna
be so easy!"
And so, I write a proposal. I raise some money. I call my aunt down in Alabama.
Explain the project to her, and I say, "I'm looking for a house that can be project headquarters. Can you
help me find something?" And she calls me back a couple of days later and she's like "I have the
perfect house"
house." Um, it's...the house is in, um, just behind
my mother's childhood home. It's built by my father's father for his very
best friend. It is perfect, right? Exclamation mark.
And so, in December, I rent a car and I drive down
to Alabama, uh, stopping at every thrift store along the way, and buying all these t-shirts.
And, on December 23rd, I arrive in Alabama with a
friend. And, you can see the house from the road. Right?
She had forgotten to tell me that the house had been abandoned for the last five years. [laughs]
That no one had really lived in the house since that time, and there's like a
little path that goes around the back of the house that used to be a driveway. And
we drive around to the back door, and my aunt and my mother have cut a
hole through all of the nature in to the back door with a
chainsaw. And, my dream,
my project is really just an old mattress thrown on a 1970s
vinyl floor, in a house that smells of old
chicken bones and,
shut up, and animals and things that live on the edges of
places. Right? So, I go to bed that night, and, um,
I'm laying on this mattress on the floor, and I just start to cry. And I
cry, and I cry, and I cry some more. And, you know, I just think I spent
my whole life running away from this place
that, um, you know, traveling the world, doing these things, and all
of this comes
to, you know, laying on on the floor in the middle of the night, waiting for
ghosts or kudzu to crawl up through the floor boards and, and
uh, lay down next to me. And, the whole night, I can't
stop looking around me, because all I can think about are all of the heat-
seeking snakes that are in the house, right, as soon as I'm still, I'm gonna
feel that
cold thing slither up next to me and lay down.
So, some time about, uh,
uh, you know, in the very early morning, I guess, I...I close my eyes and I fell asleep for
a minute. And I wake up, and it was the most beautiful crisp, clear
December morning. Uh, the light in Alabama at this time is absolutely
beautiful. It was Christmas Eve,
and I get up out of the bed, and go over to the kitchen, and clean off a little place
and make my tea, and I sit down on this borrowed stool. And, I look around the room and
I realize that, you know, it may have, uh, 1970s vinyl on the
floor, but the walls are completely covered with heart pine paneling.
And, I don't know if you know this, but these really old broad heart pine boards from
the south were made from the Longleaf Pine trees which were called the giants
of the South. And so they're hundreds and hundreds of years old, these trees, before they make
these
boards. And, so I think, I'm just going to clean one board, and um, you know, just see,
what the wood looks like. So, I go over and I clean this one board, and it is
sooo beautiful. I mean the wood is spectacular, right
spectacular, right. And, I stand there, and I look, and I think, "OK, I
I can clean one more board. So, I clean one more board, and when I finish with
that board, I realize that I can...do have the resolve within me, maybe,
to clean one more.
And, so, you know, throughout the day, board by board, I
move through the room. And, by the end of the day, the sun is setting back behind the kitchen
there, I sit back down on the stool, and I've cleaned the
entire, uh, room. And, I think, you know, I think I can do this.
So, the next morning I get up, and I um, I get a phone, and I start calling
these women who used to quilt with my grandmothers. Right? And, I'm like: This is gonna be
so great. You're going to love it. It's like New York City Fashion and
Vogue, and everything that you could dream of...and they so don't love it. [laughter]
They could care less. You know?
They talked to me about their kids, and their grandkids, and common acquaintances,
and church, and their gardens. And, you know, I show them the shirts.
And one of the ladies says you know, "My grandmother would say about that, 'Honey,
those stitches are so big that you could get your toenails caught up in
'em.'" [laughter]
And they laugh, and they talked to me about planting turnip greens, and the importance
of that.  But...what...
Turnip greens are really important. My aunt once asked
me...I was telling her about a boy that I was kind of interested in, and she said, "Yeah, but can he grow turnip
greens? (Laughs) It's true. (Laughs)
So, um, but what I did find out from having these conversations with
the community of my childhood was that the mills had closed down. And that there
were women and men who were out of work, and maybe they would want this work. And, so I
ran a little ad in the paper that said "Part-time hand-sewing and quilting."
And about 60 women called, and about, uh, 20 women stuck. And, we sewed the 200
one-of-a-kind shirts, and I brought them to New York Fashion Week. And, we sent out a little catalog.
And, the first person to walk to the door is Julie Gillheart, who was then the buyer
from Barney's New York. And, Julie swoops back in a few days later with her buyers, and
they look at all the t-shirts and they go, "We'll have 12 like this, and 12 like this, and 12 like this.
And I'm like, wait...wait a minute...
These are one-of-a-kind shirts, you know, like, wait, how are we gonna make twelve shirts like this
this that says, you know, Smith Family Reunion from Roanoke
Virginia. I'm like...this is nu...
And, they said, "Just make something like it." And, um, we made
them, and
um, uh, we brought them to New York. We took
the orders. Julia Gillheart and Sally Singer from Vogue
went out into the world, and told everybody about the work we were
doing. Um, all the t-shirts had been made with all of the seams on the
inside out. That night, when I
sewed that first shirt back together again, um,
I had, uh, turned everything to the outside, so it was raw and exposed, kind of
like I was in that moment of my life. And,
this style, this idea of everything being turned on the outside, has really
become our signature style. So, it's fifteen years later and I'm still at
home. We have about 32 women who still sew these
shirts in the field by hand, everything completely sewn by hand. We have, uh,
about 40 of us that work in our studio. We have just opened a new
machine sewn textile factory in hopes of recreating
this community of my childhood. We have a café...um...
People come from all over the world now to Florence, Alabama, to sit with us, to sew with us...
to
eat with us, to laugh, to tell stories
Um, and I live at home.
And, um, you know, some days it feels like I'm still cleaning heart pine boards,
board by board. And, I live really close to nature. And I can
sometimes feel it coming out of the edges and up around and into my
life, but, um, I guess I kind of like it that way. So,
So, thank you.